non
[Musique]
vite vite vite j'avais tout le monde est
pressé ladite 18th en dépêchant vite
vite vite dans l'eau déchaînant
dépêchons-nous allez aimer année tout
est prêt ça y est sous les bagages ni va
vous êtes prêts à les prêts sont prêts
sont l'heure tourne et c'est parti enfin
presque partout
[Musique]
oh là là là là qu'elle ment on n'est pas
arrivé au les enfants non ne commençait
pas votre comédie
[Musique]
nous pas question de s'arrêter on est
pressé
[Musique]
ralalala on perd du temps et l'autoroute
est complètement bouché
on en impôts des heures je sens que je
vais craquer
[Musique]
il
je crois que les petits what what ou
vont prendre les choses en main
[Musique]
tout le monde sont là de repos on va
vous montrer quelque chose eh oui il
n'ya pas que l'autoroute
s'il ya trop de monde
emprunter les petites routes et au
passage profitez en pour admirer la
campagne
allez c'est gratuit aujourd'hui à lévis
et oui pour tout le monde
bonjour comme ça
[Musique]
comme ils sont mignons un pardon du
fromage mais nous merci
[Musique]
et puis on petit bouquet et les enfants
peuvent jouer sur l'herbe
[Musique]
allez maintenant prenez votre temps et
bon voyage
[Musique]
et papa soit c'est bien retenu la leçon
que maintenant il s'arrête toutes les 5
minutes et il fait le guide vous pouvez
ignorer la mirabelle dessin
architectural du portail de cet édifice
qui par rapport à un portail qui
constitue sans doute est cet art est et
sera un sacré papa soit c'est quand même
plus sympa de voyager comme ça
vous aussi faites connu
[Musique]
et au revoir merci à thomas tôt
ici
oh